VIVEK KWATRA: Hello everyone.
I'm Vivek Kwatra.
I'm a research scientist
at Google.
I'm joined by my colleagues,
Matthias
Grundmann and John Gregg.
Today we will tell you about
the video stabilization
technology that is available on
YouTube and also give you
some insights on how it works
and how you can use it to
improve your videos.
We'll show you some fun videos
today, but along the way,
we'll also try to tell you about
the technical details
behind the algorithms.
To give you an overview of the
talk, we will start by talking
about video stabilization.
Then, we will give you some
information about how we adapt
that to work for mobile phones,
which have rolling
shutter cameras.
We will then take you through
the life of a video as it goes
through the YouTube
stabilizer.
And finally, we are announcing
new features in the YouTube
upload API today that allow you
to apply enhancements to
your videos programmatically.
So if you want to find out how
to enhance your videos by
adding some lines of code to
your programs, then stay to
the end where we will show
you a demo of that.
So let me start by showing you
an example of what we call a
casual video.
This video here is shot by
somebody running with a camera
strapped onto their head.
So it's amazing that we have
cameras which are light enough
that you can strap them on
your head while running.
But that does not prevent the
resulting video from giving
you a headache.
Thankfully, we have a solution
for that problem.
So this is the same video after
it has been processed by
the YouTube stabilizer.
You'll note that the video is
much less shaky, the camera
looks much more stable, and
the video is much more
pleasant to watch.
Here is the same video.
We're showing you side by side
with the original on the left
and the stabilized result
on the right.
One thing to note here is that
to obtain this result, we only
look at the pixels
in the video.
We only analyze the pictures.
We don't have any information
about the
camera at this point.
So how do you do this on
YouTube if you want to
stabilize your own videos.
If you go to the Watch page of
one of your own videos, then
you will see these extra
buttons at the bottom.
And one of these buttons is the
enhancement button, which
takes you to the
enhancement UI.
And here you can apply different
kinds of filters and
effects to your videos.
You can apply some
fun effects.
You can color correct by
applying the art effects.
And of course, you
can stabilize.
And once you click on stabilize,
you'll see this
split screen viewer, which gives
you a comparison between
the original video and a preview
of the stabilized
result so you can compare them
and see if you like it.
Note that at this point the
stabilizer is actually running
live at the back end and
streaming results to the user
in real time, which is also why
the preview is run at a
low resolution.
The final video is processed at
a much higher resolution.
And once you are satisfied with
the video, you can go to
the top right where you
have the Save button.
You can save it by overriding
the current video ID, or you
can save it as a copy, which
creates a new video.
And then the video is processed
for stabilization.
And then you go to your video
manager or uploads page where
you'll see a copy of the video
up here where you can play the
video to see how the stabilized
result looks like.
So now, we're going to
the watch page of
the stabilized video.
You can see the stabilized
video here.
We're also showing you the
original video in the bottom
left to compare the shaky result
with what you get after
stabilization.
Of course, you can apply this
effect on any video of your
choice that you have uploaded.
But we also try to try to help
by offering some suggestions
when we detect automatically
that the video is shaky.
So in this case, the blue bar
at the bottom is offering a
suggestion to the user to
stabilize the video.
You can click on the Preview
button, which again shows you
the split screen UI but this
time right on the watch page.
Again, you can compare
the before and after.
Note that as a user, you don't
need to fiddle with any
sliders or tweak
any parameters.
It's just a one click
stabilization solution.
You just click stabilize
and you get the result.
So now that we've shown you some
videos, let's talk about
how it actually works.
When talking about
stabilization, one can broadly
categorize into two
main types.
You can talk about in-camera
stabilization where you
perform stabilization on the
device while you are
capturing the video.
And when you do that, one issue
is that you're only
looking at the video as you're
seeing it so far.
You can't really see what's
going to happen in the future.
And that limits your ability
to do stabilization.
Also, you are limited by
the processing power
of the single device.
The second approach is what
we call post-process
stabilization.
This is where the video is
already captured and encoded,
and in our case, uploaded
to YouTube.
And we apply stabilization
after the fact.
So our stabilization is a
post-process approach.
And the advantage that we have
here is that since we have the
entire video at our disposal,
we can do stabilization, for
example, for the case
where you're
walking with your camera.
So there's low frequency
bouncing motions, which you
can't stabilize if you're just
looking in the past.
Also, you can distribute the
computation in the cloud in
this post-process setting.
So you can use multiple machines
to do much heavier
processing than possible
in a single device.
There are three main steps
in doing Post-process
stabilization.
You start by estimating
the shaky camera
parts of the video.
This is where you try to figure
out or recover how the
user was moving the camera while
capturing the video.
The second step is to smooth
the camera motion, the
original shaky camera motion,
to obtain the stabilized
camera path.
And finally, you want to render
a new video or new
movie from the viewpoints of
these stabilized camera parts.
So let's look at an example.
Here we have a shaky video that
we want to stabilize.
And once we take it through
these three steps, we have the
stabilized camera part.
Now you see this red
rectangle here.
This is our visualization of
this new camera position.
You can think of this as a
virtual window that tries to
move counter to the original
shaky camera motion.
In other words, this tries to
stick to the background in the
video so that you get
a stabilized result.
And to get this stabilized
result, we essentially take
the pixels within this rectangle
and render them in
the final video.
But it's not really final yet.
So what you see in the top
is a stabilized video.
But you also see these
extra black
borders around the video.
And that's because when there
is too much motion in the
video, this virtual window
overcompensates for it and
goes outside the valid
bounds of the video.
And we don't really want that.
That's sort of annoying
to watch.
So a solution here
is what we call
stabilization by cropping.
And the idea here is that we
can start with the same
virtual window.
But we shrink it a little bit
to get rid of some of the
contents around the border
of the frame.
And more importantly, we force
this crop window to always
stay within the bounds of
the frame rectangle.
What that means is that while
you lose some content around
the border, you always get
pixels which are well-defined.
So you get a final stabilized
video, which
looks nice to watch.
There is some content
which is lost.
But overall, the result
is better.
So let's get back to the three
steps I talked about.
And we'll talk about
them one by one.
So let's talk about estimating
the shaky camera parts from a
given video.
Remember what I told you was
that we only look at the
pixels within the video to
compute the camera motion.
So in this case, what I'm
showing you here are these
green dots, which are what
we call local features.
These are pixels which have high
gradients in the x and y
direction, which means these
are things like corners.
So if you look at the windows
in the building, the corners
of the window are good
places to track
or have local features.
And that is because you
can track them in
the previous frame.
By matching appearance, you can
figure out where did each
of these points come from
in the previous frame?
And once we have these features,
we want to fit a
camera motion to them.
But there is one important point
here, which is we don't
want to treat all features
equally.
Since the camera motion only
affects the pixels in the
background, you don't want to
take into account things like
a person walking in
the foreground or
a car driving by.
And we detect that automatically
and figure out
which features are background
features, shown in green, and
which features are foreground
features.
And those features
are shown in red.
And once we have these features
that we can use for
motion estimation, we finally
compute what the actual shaky
camera part was.
At this point, I'll hand over to
Matthias who will tell you
how we actually do the
motion estimation.
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN:
Thank you, Vivek.
Hey.
I'm Matthias.
And I'm going to talk about how
we actually model the 2D
camera path.
So Vivek initially mentioned,
we start by having our
original video, and we extract
features at these gradient
locations and track them with
respect to the previous frame.
So we get all these little
displacement vectors.
Now in order to stabilize the
video, we would need to
stabilize the motion of each
and every of these vectors,
which is, of course,
computationally quite expensive.
So what we do instead is we try
to summarize the overall
motion of all these feature
points with just a few
numbers, what we call
a motion model.
Let's look at some of the motion
models that one can
employ in this setting.
Well, the easiest motion model
is that of a translation.
In a translation, we only have
translation x and y or
superimposed.
So altogether, we're looking
at two degrees of freedom.
And if we use that to stabilize
the video, we see
it's still very shaky.
And it's very shaky because
there are some degrees of
freedom missing.
And that is the role
and the scale.
So let's add that to
our motion model.
In this case, we have
a similarity.
A similarity has now translation
x and y as well as
scale and rotation.
So we're looking at four
degrees of freedom.
And if we use that to stabilize
the video, we see it
is not shaky, but it's
still quite wobbly.
And that's because there are
additional degrees of freedom
that are missing.
And that is the yaw and the
pitch rotation of the camera.
So if we add that to our motion
model, we obtain what
he call a homography.
So we have all the four degrees
of freedom of the
previous motion model, but
now we also have skew and
perspective degrees
of freedom.
All together, we have eight
degrees of freedom here.
And if we use that to stabilize
the video, we see
this is adequate to summarize
the motion.
So while we use this homography
in our back end,
for the ease of explanation,
I will only focus on the
similarity case, meaning four
degrees of freedom over time,
translation x, y, scale,
and rotation.
Now what we can do is we can
plot the amount of each degree
of freedom over time.
And so we get a curve.
So here, first we show you the
translation of x over time,
the blue curve.
The translation y, you see it's
going up and down because
that is the walking motion
that we measure.
We're looking now
at the scale.
You see the scale is going
down because we're
moving into the scene.
And finally, the rotation, which
is just wiggly, in this
case, left and right.
Now that we model basically
the 2D camera motion with
these four degrees of freedom
over time, we can start
stabilizing or smoothing them,
which is the second step of
our algorithm.
So here we just show the
translation x and the
translation y.
The original camera path
is shown in red.
And we're trying to approximate
it with a stable
path that is shown in blue.
This is our result.
So you see the stable path
has some properties.
When we started our project, we
asked ourselves what would
be the property of a good,
stable path if a
cinematographer would
have captured it.
Well, a cinematographer would
use stabilization equipment,
for example, a tripod.
So you would have segments in
your stabilized video that
basically would have no motion
at all, meaning a constant
segment shown here in green.
Or a cinematographer would have
used a dolly or a pan
where you have nice constant
velocity, which reflects
itself in a linear path
shown here in yellow.
You see the remaining arcs are
basically parabolic segments,
what we call ease in and ease
out transitions so that you
can transition between
the constant
and the linear segments.
And so our goal is now, given
this original shaky path shown
in red, to compute this stable
path that is only composed out
of linear, constant, and
parabolic paths under one very
important constraint.
And that is the size
of the crop window.
When we look at the crop window,
as Vivek initially
mentioned it, if we have a very
large crop window, and we
have to stay within the frame
bound, we can't really move
around without hitting
the frame border.
So we can't really offset
any camera shake.
Now the smaller the crop window,
the more shake we can
compensate for.
And this reflects itself very
nicely as an envelope around
the shaky camera path
that we measure.
So the smaller the crop window,
the larger an envelope
around that shaky camera path.
And now within this envelope,
we're trying to find our
stable path that will be only
composed out of constant
linear and parabolic segments.
Let's look at a little
interactive visualization of
how you can imagine this
solution works.
So here we see our original
shaky path in red.
And now we'll start increasing
the bounds over time, and you
will see how more stable the
blue path will become.
What's nice about our solution
is its robust perturbations.
If I move it around, as long
as I'm staying within the
envelope, the path
doesn't change.
I can use only constant
paths to
approximate the stable path.
Or I can use linear paths, in
which case now I have these
junctions here.
I can also use just parabolic
paths, which are very smooth
but nonzero throughout.
Or I can use a specific
weighting that we employ in
YouTube, which finds a nice
sweet spot between these three
types of paths and
is shown here.
Now that we have the original
path and we have the
stabilized path, we can finally
synthesize a new movie
that looks like as if it would
have been taken from this
stable viewpoint, which is the
last step in our algorithm.
The stable path, you can think
of as this virtual camera,
that is shown here in red
at this crop window.
And so in this step, really all
we need to do is simply
apply a crop.
And that will result in the
stable video at the top.
So let's look at some few more
examples from YouTube.
So here are some of the
properties highlighted in a
real video.
If we can fit a tripod model,
there will be no motion in the
stable result at all.
And now that the motion of the
original camera picks up, and
the frame rectangle has to stay
within the frame bounds,
you see there's also motion
in the stabilized result.
But it's very nicely smooth.
You have this constant
velocity pans.
Again, no motion at all in the
beginning, nice tripod model.
And now we have nice
accelerations, constant pans,
nice decelerations.
So the whole result
looks very smooth.
And a lot of the shake that was
in the y direction is gone
from the result.
Another example here recorded
on a bike in Cairo.
And so you see a lot of this
high frequency perturbations
in the y direction.
And it's completely gone in
the stabilized result.
The stabilized result really
looks like just the handle
bars moving very smoothly.
In the second part, I
would like to talk
about solving a problem.
And that is rolling
shutter removal.
It's a little bit independent
from video stabilization.
To motivate the problem, let's
look at the following example.
Here we took a video
that we recorded
with an Android phone.
And we deliberately
shook the camera.
What you see, it's not
just camera shake.
It's like these non rigid,
wobbly distortions that pose a
problem here.
And so our stabilization
algorithm does rolling shutter
rectification as well.
So we can take this original
video shown on left, we can
produce this rolling shutter
removed result on the right.
And you see it's
still a video.
There's a person walking
on the bridge.
But all the distortions
are gone.
Let's look at a little bit
into the details why this
problem actually exist.
It exists because there
are two types
of electronic shutters.
The classic shutter is that
of a global shutter.
In the global shutter, the
image is captured at one
instant in time.
So we snap a picture
or a video frame.
Then we move the camera
slightly.
We snap another picture.
And then, we snap
another picture.
However, most cellphones
use what is
called a rolling shutter.
So here is an image that's not
captured in one instant in
time, but one scan
line at a time.
So what you get is the camera is
moving during the capture.
And so instead of a rectified
image, you
get this good effect.
And if the camera is actually
vibrating during the capture,
you get this wobbly result.
If you compare global with a
rolling shutter, you see the
global shutter nicely rectified,
the rolling
shutter, all the houses
are skewed.
And so when you plot the scan
lines over time how they get
recorded, what you basically
see is they are slanted.
They are offset.
The image is not captured at one
instant in time anymore.
Now if you don't account
for this--
here I'll show you an original
video taken from a helicopter.
You see all these rolling
shutter distortions.
And so in our initial launch of
the YouTube Stabilizer in
2011, we didn't account for
rolling shutter yet.
You see the result is more
stable, but there's still all
these wobbly distortions
that remain.
So how can we solve
this problem?
Something that makes the
solution more challenging is
that the speed of the readout
varies across cameras.
So for more high end cameras,
you would basically have these
blocks a little bit
more aligned.
And then if the cameras take
longer, you will basically
have a more slanted
arrangement.
And at YouTube, we only
have the video.
We don't know which camera,
which setting, or which scene
you recorded.
And so our solution is
calibration free.
And the idea is basically
instead of using one motion
model, we use multiple ones.
We use one that describes
the motion of the
top side of the frame.
And then the camera moves to
a different configuration.
So we have a motion model
for the middle frame.
And we have a motion model
for the bottom frame.
We actually use 10 motion models
and a little bit of
interpolation, but this
is like the simplified
explanation of it.
When you use this new mixture
model to account for the
camera motion, you can
take this video.
And then after our launch of
rolling shutter removal in
YouTube, we produced the
following result.
Nicely accounts for all the
wobbly distortions.
Here's another video from
Citizen Tube, also
recorded on a bike.
Citizen Tube is a crowd
casted news site.
So you see a lot of wobbly
distortions in this case.
And here is our rectified
and stabilized result.
And one more time side by side
for better comparison.
In the next part of the talk,
I would like to give you a
little overview what's actually
happening behind the
YouTube stabilizer that uses
those two algorithms to
produce the result or some of
the results we earlier saw.
So here just to motivate it, or
to remind you again, this
is the enhancement UI
where we detect that
your video is shaky.
So we offer you this
preview button.
You simply click
on the button.
And then we compute the
stabilized result in real time
and stream it to the user.
We also detect that this video,
in addition to video
shake, was corrupted
by rolling shutter.
So we do rolling shutter
rectification in real time on
top of the stabilization.
Let's look at what's going
on behind the scenes.
So we have our video here.
And we start by clicking
on Preview.
And the moment you click on
Preview, a server request is
sent to our cloud to start
the stabilization.
The first step is to compute
a camera path.
Remember, this is just
extracting the features,
getting displacement vectors,
and then getting
the original 2D path.
Because we only look
at frame pairs,
this is highly parallel.
So we can simply
distribute this
across many, many machines.
Once we have the 2D camera path,
we can then send it off
to our stabilization engine
to compute the
stable camera path.
There's a little
addition here.
And that is I haven't talked
about what's actually the size
of the crop window.
And we can do this
dynamically.
And we'll look into
this in a bit.
And the last part, once we have
our stable path, we can
apply the cropping.
Again, this is done on frame.
So this can be done
in parallel.
And then in the end,
we live-stream the
result to the user.
I'd like to highlight that
this pipeline can be run
independently.
So the actual throughput of our
system is so high that we
can compute the stabilization
and rolling shutter
rectification on low resolution
video in real time
and stream it to you.
I'd like to highlight two things
of this pipeline in
more detail.
First, you auto crop.
So I haven't really talked about
what is the size of the
crop window.
What we would like to do is we
would like to maximize the
crop window so that we can
offset most of the shake but
also give you most of
your image content.
Don't crop too much.
What we do is we do
it adaptively.
So what we see here is we start
with a crop window that
is rather large because we don't
have a lot of shake in
this segment of the video.
And now the user will basically
start shaking the
camera more.
And so the crop window now
adaptively contracts over time
to account for this.
And here the user now will stop
shaking the camera as
much as before.
And so now the crop window will
smoothly and adaptively
expand over time.
So we measure the
amount of shake.
And based on that, we size
the crop window.
Another challenge that we face
at YouTube is that videos are
often pre-composited in
some other software.
So for example, you
have overlays.
Overlays are not part
of the video.
And so if you don't account
for that, what happens is
these overlays dance around.
And the user that's not
familiar with the
video will see this.
It's not a satisfactory
result.
So what we do is we detect if
major overlays are present.
And in that case, we don't
stabilize those parts of the
video at all to avoid that.
And once the overlay fades out,
we detect it and then
nicely transition into the
stabilized result.
So since we launched
our system, we have
gathered user responses.
And in particular, two of them
are A, when we detect that a
video is shaky, and we suggest
stabilization to the user, how
many actually accept
the suggestion?
And of those that do, how many
keep the stabilized result?
And the response is collected
over millions of videos is 55%
accept stabilization after
we suggest that the
video might be shaky.
And of those that do, 95% keep
the stabilized result.
So only 5% go back to the
original because they didn't
like the stabilized result.
Or the Stabilizer might have
not performed that well.
So far I talked about
stabilization of videos.
But what we can do is we can
actually do stabilization of
photo bursts as well.
And this is deployed in Google+
Auto Awesome feature
that you heard about in
yesterday's keynote.
So while there are many other
algorithms used in this suite,
the Stabilization is used
prominently in three of them.
That is Google+ MOTION, Google+
HDR, and Google+ SMILE.
In Google+ MOTION, what we do is
we take a photo burst, and
we create this animation
shown on top out of it.
And so what is desirable here
is basically to nicely align
the background, get rid of all
the alignment issues so that
the foreground really
pops, right?
Now that the background is
aligned, the foreground object
really comes out in
this animation.
We also use it in Google+ HDR.
When you take an exposure
stack, when you use your
camera in bracketing mode, it's
rarely the case that you
use a tripod.
So there will be a little
bit of camera shake.
And so what we do is we run the
stabilization upfront so
that the images are nicely
aligned before we apply the
HDR, which then reduces
ghosting.
What we can also do is
we can align faces.
So if you take a photo burst of
your family, we can align
the faces and then create a new
composite that hasn't been
taken by you where we try that
all the faces that are shown
are smiling.
And so here are some
more examples.
You see the animation that we
created with foreground,
waterfall, and finally
the smile where we
create this new canvas.
And with that, I hand
it over to John.
JOHN GREGG: Thank
you, Matthias.
Hi, my name is John.
I'm an engineer on the video
editing team at YouTube.
And just for the last part of
our talk, I'm going to talk to
you about a new feature that
we're launching today, which
allows developers to take
advantage of the stabilization
feature in a new API for
enhancing uploads.
So here you see the user-facing
enhancement API.
There's a wide variety of
options, including these
stylized filters, trimming your
video, color correction,
and stabilize.
And what we've done is taken the
two most popular features
of enhancement, the stabilizer
and the Auto Fix, which we
could talk in a lot
more detail about.
But it's basically a histogram
stretcher that's temporally
smooth over the video.
So it improves the contrast
and colors in
pretty much any video.
We've taken those two features
and added them to
the YouTube v3 API.
So any application that uploads
to YouTube can add,
with just a couple lines of
code, instructions to apply
these effects after the
video's been uploaded.
So I'm just going to walk
through a quick demo of it.
So this is just running
an app engine.
Imagine any application that's
capturing video and uploading
it to YouTube.
This one's just called
John's Uploader.
So let's upload this video,
which didn't work.
But it would look like this.
So this is just playing the
raw file in the app.
So in the camera, for example.
And we're going to publish
this to YouTube.
Just check a few boxes,
publish it.
And here it's been published.
You see a message that it's
processing and also that the
video edits are being
processed.
So while we can do the low
resolution preview nearly
instantaneously, processing a
higher resolution does take a
few minutes.
But I happen to have already
uploaded a copy of this video.
And you can see the stabilized
version on YouTube versus the
shaky version in my app.
So how did I do this?
This is using the YouTube v3
API, which is where this new
feature is now available.
It's just two Boolean parameters
on the video's
insert instructions called
autolevels and stabilize to
apply each of those effects.
These are simply Boolean
parameters.
As we've already described, we
have pieces of a technology to
automatically compute the
optimal parameters.
So you don't have to
worry about sliders
or complicated controls.
The edits are all performed
in the cloud.
So again, you don't have to
worry about implementing these
things on a device, which also
allows the user to revert back
to the original version, if for
whatever reason they're
not satisfied.
So here's a code sample.
This is using the API library
for Python in App Engine.
So this is just a request
setting the body and title,
description, and the bytes
of the upload.
And it really is just
two lines of code
added to this request.
This is actually taken from my
app so it's grabbing the
values of those check boxes
and setting stabilize and
autolevels parameters.
And that's really
as easy as that.
So this is available today.
We hope app developers
find it useful.
And with that, the
end of our talk.
So just to summarize, we
talked about the video
stabilization technology, which
compensates for a lot of
the common problems with
casual video, including
rolling shutter.
And then the enhancement API,
which allows developers to add
these corrections right
in the applications.
So thank you for coming.
One last example to
leave you with.
And if you want to scan
this QR code, you
can rate the talk.
But with that, we'd be happy
to take any questions.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Well, I've really enjoyed
using the stabilization.
So I'm using a GoPro camera,
which I imagine a lot of users
for kind of high action
photography are using
a camera like that.
But it has a very
wide angle lens.
And I think the model that
you're using for stabilization
doesn't account for the kind of
distortion that you'd get
in an extremely wide angle
lens like that.
So you get some very bizarre
kind of distortion effects
that propagate across the field
of the virtual camera as
you're moving it.
And I was wondering if you're
aware of that and your plans
to try to detect different lens
models to try to correct
them more accurately?
JOHN GREGG: Do you want
to talk about that?
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: Yeah.
So we are aware that there is
a problem with GoPro cameras
because of the wide
field of view.
This is actually
a GoPro camera.
And if you use it in the
more narrow field of
view, it works decent.
But the wider field of
view is a challenge.
There is a challenge to
basically detect which
settings you use just
from the video file.
But yeah, we are aware
of the problem.
But it, so far, has been a
difficult problem to solve.
AUDIENCE: I have another
question if nobody else is
going to come up to
the microphone.
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So I've also been
doing photography mounted on a
quadcopter.
So there's often a kind of a
form of vibration, a very high
frequency vibration
in the camera.
And I don't know, is your
rolling shutter algorithm able
to deal with something
like that?
Or maybe detect a certain
frequency of vibration to try
to more accurately get rid of
the rolling shutter effect?
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: So our
rolling shutter algorithm
detects rolling shutter.
Now the question is, of course,
how crazy you see
distortion.
Because we do it automatically,
we calibrated
it for the most common
use cases.
So we can work on vibrating
[INAUDIBLE]
from helicopters a little
bit, from driving cars.
But if it gets too crazy, if
simply the camera motion just
becomes too large during the
capturing process, it might
not always work.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, well I wonder
if it's also like the blades
of a small quadcopter
they might be
like 80 Hertz or something.
So maybe a higher frequency
range then you're used to
maybe detecting automatically
as that.
And you might not be detecting
how to actually get rid of the
rolling shutter in that case.
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: Right.
For those specialized cases,
we might not always do a
perfect job because we strive
basically for this one click
solution, with the absence
of any sliders.
And so that might not be the
best use case for that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
VIVEK KWATRA: Just to
add to that, it's a
calibration free approach.
So if we're doing it on YouTube
after it has been uploaded.
So we don't necessarily know
always which camera is used to
compute that.
So we need to know, or we need
to compute this information
just based on the pixels.
So we do as best as we can, but
we can always strive to
improve it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So as you talk, you're using the
software measure to detect
the motion of the film
or the camera, right?
So is there any possibility in
the future that you can upload
your motion vector with a video
to the YouTube so that
you can just better stabilize
the video?
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: John?
JOHN GREGG: It's a good idea.
I think it's something
that we think about.
But right now it's too
complex, I guess.
And we want to have a general
purpose solution that works
even when we don't have
that information.
So having the extra information
would probably help.
It's just a matter of working
it into the system.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And another question.
So you upload the 1080p video,
and after the cropping, the
video becomes smaller.
But on the YouTube,
so we still are
watching the 1080p video.
So the quality drops
dramatically.
So why are we still watching
in the 1080p definition?
Because it's not the 1080p
definition anymore.
JOHN GREGG: Right.
We do scale the video
back up to the
original size after cropping.
So it appears to be the
same resolution.
Although, you're right.
There's a bit of a loss
of actual image data.
VIVEK KWATRA: We do do some
sharpening on the video after
scaling it.
But yes, you do lose resolution
because you're
cropping it.
AUDIENCE: So that leads
into what I was
going to ask about--
effect this has on compression
quality because presumably,
then the motion estimation that
the codec is doing is
much simpler because you've
moved it into a more
[INAUDIBLE] domain.
And out with the domain where
the codec tends to fall over
when you aren't doing
that to it.
Did you notice that?
The difference between the codec
performance is improved
before and after this?
I'm just interested if
you measured that.
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: So,
I think, in principle,
definitely having less shake in
the video should give you
better compression performance
with lower bit rate.
It would be interesting if you
would have actually the raw
video available.
We already have the encoded,
compressed video.
So it might not be really
a benefit for us.
AUDIENCE: Depends on what
it's shot with.
If I uploaded an uncompressed
video.
But yeah, most people already
give compressed.
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: Right.
So there might be some
benefit to it.
AUDIENCE: So that leads me to
sort of another couple of
questions, which is those videos
have motion vectors in.
But they're probably really
bad because they've been
estimated by a camera.
So presumably you ignore those
and just look at pixels.
But do you look at--
once you've done your coplanar
recomposition of the thing,
you could potentially
reconstruct better pixels
across the motion from the fact
there are multiple shots
of the same piece.
So if there's some bit that's
been squished into low
frequency because of the DCTs,
you could actually construct
better pixels from a frame
going off this.
I'm assuming you haven't
looked at that.
But is that something you've
considered looking at?
VIVEK KWATRA: That's
a good suggestion.
We haven't necessarily looked
into that because we were just
focused on the stabilization.
That's sort of an additional
enhancement you could do.
You could think of that as sort
of super resolution or--
AUDIENCE: It's sort of like
HDR, but for sharpness.
VIVEK KWATRA: And definitely
that's a good suggestion,
something that can definitely
enhance a video.
We'll have to think about.
AUDIENCE: And that takes me to
sort of the third iteration of
this thought, which is grumbling
about codecs.
The codecs all have this stupid,
sort of dimensional
squares moving around in space
models, whereas you're
constructing a much more fluid
six degrees of freedom model
for how the thing is moving,
which implies you construct a
different kind of codec that
plays better with the GPU
where you say OK, if we actually
understand how the
camera's moving, we understand
what would be good triangles
and textures, we could feed
something through to that.
And people are starting to do
research on codecs that are
written entirely in JavaScript
and WebGL to take
advantage of that.
I think this stuff will be
great to feed into that
because if you start from a game
or something where you've
already got the [? GL ?]
surfaces straightforward.
But you seem to be doing a
fairly good job of saying, OK,
this should be textured.
And then we could decide where
the tri-meshes go depending on
how coherent they are.
This is the beginning
of a really
interesting new kind of codec.
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: Thank you.
Yeah.
VIVEK KWATRA: [INAUDIBLE]
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So kind of
two questions.
When you're reconstructing the
new smoothed camera path,
there seems to be a loss of
parts where you have chosen to
reconstruct it so it looks
like a professional
photographer or so it follows
a particular, as you say, to
keep a still image of
particular parts.
So I was wondering how you
optimize within all of those
constraints because it seems
like quite a big optimization
problem to be doing
in real time.
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: So we
haven't talked really about
the details.
But if you're familiar with
solving systems, usually
people use something like
a least-square solver.
This boils down to
a L1 solver.
We have a little bit of the math
details, well actually
all of the math details, up on
the Google research block and
wrote a paper about it.
So if you're really interested
on how that constraint
solution works, how you set up
the equations, and how you
find the solution, you're
more than welcome to
check out that paper.
AUDIENCE: And the other question
was is there any Open
Source code for any parts of
this apart from the stuff
that's commonly done like--
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: It's
not Open Source.
But it's this new API.
And we encourage you to use that
so you can leverage all
through this whole distributed
pipeline that we set up to do
this in a highly scalable
and performant way.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Really cool talk.
I was just curious it sounded
like you do linear segments
with parabolic transitions
between them.
Have you uploaded like real
Hollywood videos just to see
what real cinema photographers
do as far as their curves?
Or do different cinematographers
have slightly
different curves where you could
apply it in the style of
this person or that person?
Have you done any of that sort
of analysis even just
internally?
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: That's
a great suggestion.
Basically, I'd like to stress a
point, what we're doing here
is we're trying to mimic
certain moves
cinematographers do.
And so these are really
just a constant,
linear parabolic arcs.
Cinematographers in many
settings, there's a very
artistic note to it.
So it's a good suggestion.
But I think the space of camera
motions would be much
more complex.
And so we're not doing
exactly what a
cinematographer would do.
We're just mimicking these
certain moves here.
AUDIENCE: Cool stuff.
Thanks.
VIVEK KWATRA: Thank you.
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: Any
more questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Following up on that last one,
you talked about dolly
tracking and tripods.
But there is a whole bunch
of other motion things.
There's steadicam, there's
Louma cranes,
and things like that.
And they all have different
characteristics.
So you can probably extend
the model of it there.
The other fun thing would be to
say, if you've got a movie
that's using this for effect--
if you put "The Blair Witch
Project" through this, you
make it a very different
movie.
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: Correct.
Thank you.
JOHN GREGG: All right.
Thanks everyone for coming.
VIVEK KWATRA: Thank
you very much.
MATTHIAS GRUNDMANN: Thank
you for coming.